hello and welcome once again to Android
developer office hours my name is Joe
melon I have with me today dev rel
people Alexander Lucas ray Domeier
Trevor John's and from google
engineering friends such friendly sorry
screwed up his first kiss go an idiot
friends thank you so the first thing we
want to do is start out with a little
intro from Francesco about Google Cloud
messaging which is a new service that we
introduced at Google i/o go ahead hi
everyone Google Cloud messaging is a new
service which is evolution from the old
c2dm service which allows you to send
messages from the cloud to device um
this is an important message an
important service if you want to avoid
polling which saves battery life because
their application doesn't have to work
out the radio every X seconds or minutes
due to polling but when the data is
available on the cloud and the server
can send it down to the device the
improvement regards scalability
performance and there there is a new set
of features ap is that allows you to
send multicast messages so with one
request you can send up to a thousand
messages up to one mess to up to a
thousand different devices time to leave
so your messages can expire and and so
on and so forth no bit more other guys
please send in or call in your questions
i'm with that will start now with
questions from moderator the first
question is why doesn't Google provide
developers with more stats for the
downloads such as how users found the
app keywords chemical related apps etc
all right up
okay Thank You Trevor next question also
about Google Play how come selling apps
on Google Play is still impossible for
most of the world because of country
limitations why is Google being so
opaque on this matter okay we definitely
do want to try and you know offer google
play both for downloads in as well for
publishing it as many regions as
possible but different countries have
different legal climates and in some
places is a bit easier for us to go and
open up shop the news for others so we
definitely do want to go and you know to
expand again to as many regions as
possible it just takes a bit longer and
some places compared to others you know
it would take a very long time to go and
explain what these issues are for each
country so just in general you know
we're working on it we're trying to get
there as fast as possible great thank
you again Trevor here is a DCM question
GCM servers allow for a maximum of four
different collapse keys suppose the
servers already received and stored
messages with four different collapse
keys what happens with the next message
if it's collapse key is not among those
four ok so the collapse key concept come
from c2dm where every single message
needed to specify one collapse key the
limit of four was to avoid people to to
use infinite collapse kids to flood the
devices so we pick it up for in which
which means that you have four main
topics for which you can update your
device with messages with GCM we
introduced a non collapsible message so
you don't have to specify the collapse
key so if you need to send a big number
of messages even if it devices offline
you can use that particular one it's
important to note that it shouldn't be
used for messages that you do want to
collapse like saying the same news that
has a very same update because we will
deliver all those messages down so you
can still use this for collapse keys now
we are thinking that this restriction
for GCM doesn't make much sense anymore
so we might consider to increase the
number of collapse keys but to answer
the question what happens is
that you should not use more than four
because the results is is not definite
so if you send messages with six
different collapse keys and devices
offline for of those messages will make
the device and they're not going to need
which one of those for next question
about you see em I read somewhere that
GCM makes no guarantees regarding the
time to delivery or order of delivery of
DCM messages okay but could you give us
a rust rough estimate or target any
plans to provide stats once the system
is running smoothly okay one question at
the time times the time of delivery we
do not guarantee time of delivery for
multiple reasons one is that we have no
idea if the device is offline or online
when we received your message so if the
device is offline we just store it and
delivery when it comes back on line two
we have now say on the latest introduced
by for example the mobile network
between our server and the device the
numbers I gave at the speak when I had a
speech at I yo was that roughly we take
95 milliseconds to process a message and
this is the time to GCM takes from the
moment he receives the message to the
moment in which it sends to the to the
device the part of the question close to
two immediate it yes it is unless
there's an unique circumstance I would
say in the best possible case it's
nearly immediate um the estimate or
target a lot of it what's going on
whether the device is offline or online
correct but also like if your server
sends a message went in in Germany and
the user that receives a message is
somewhere else in the world like in
Taiwan you know we have quite a bit of
routing to do from that side of the
world of the other ones so the latency
can go up to 150 milliseconds on sex but
it's definitely if the device is
connected it's way below 17 right for
last video
and the other part was the order of
messages um what the way we send
messages downstream is when we receive a
message restore it unless the time to
live in 0 in that case we just send it
down directly but if we still a message
and a second one comes we delivered in
that order but network from your servers
to our servers does not guarantee that
if you send two message in the same
milliseconds that we were receiving it
in that exact order so if we receive
them swapped then we'll be delivered on
SWAT sending them in order in the order
in which we receive you okay right that
may not be in the order in which you
sent them to our servers correct
especially if your multi if you have a
form of servers the right the sense
messaging at the very same time depends
on the network location I think in the
last question was do we plan to provide
stats on our so we launched the version
one of stats if you as a developer login
in the android developer console you can
see stats for GCM and c2dm applications
we provide metrics of how many message
has been sent how many stores collapsed
or throttled if you had any errors in
the request and also metrics for the
registrations that the user's device are
connecting to other servers for your
application you can already see those
and we are in the work working for
providing a version 2 in which you will
be able to query the life of a message
ok thank you
alright alright I guess we didn't have
to turn those off you we could just meet
at them too but yes should we do to
share Mike's now right so that's why I
have this yellow thing in front of my
face next question from moderator is for
an app working with sensitive data what
solution would you recommend if I need
to show a login screen every time the
app comes from the background related to
that is there an easy way to determine
if your app is currently in the
background all right I think that this
is actually a question this come up at
least once before so there's probably
all right so first off at answer the
question of how do you determine if your
app is in the background all Android
applications have a life cycle when they
start up you get a on start or on create
call back and then you'll get on resume
and so on and so forth and finally on
pause on stop so these callbacks are
what allows your app to know what its
current state is and that's pretty much
the answer to your question as well too
if you want to go and display a login
dialog when your app comes back up from
the background if you just want to be on
first launch you can put it in oncreate
if you want to make it so that it
appears when it's coming back after
being in the background for a while you
can put it on in on resume you know it's
just a matter of you know how you want
to go and display this keep in mind that
you don't want to splay your login
dialog too frequently so you know be a
bit cautious about how you do use this
also it's worth noting as far as your
login screen don't go and lock that as a
separate activity there's some security
implications there that you can get it
right if you're careful but it's very
difficult to get right so my
recommendation there would be just to go
and swap out your layout for your login
form without spotting a whole new
activity but then that day I think that
should answer your question I was going
to add something which is that I have
used apps that have encrypted data in
them and they ask you for a login screen
every time you switch away from them and
switch back which is a little bit of an
annoyance oh it's very
oh yeah to call out one app in
particular one password I love the mac
version of it the android version drives
me absolutely nuts because i log in to
get my password i switch to the browser
I enter my password I go back to one
password and it's locked again and it
hasn't even been you know 30 seconds you
know that the phone already has a lock
screen so I I'd say at the very least
make this optional because it's going to
drive a lot of your users nuts to the
point where they might switch to other
apps definitely you know definitely
don't make it mandatory you know I know
and you know consider that if the user
really does want to keep their phone
secure they've probably already set a
passcode for the screen as well right
and in fairness to one pass I'm aware of
another password app that I use which is
works exactly the same way and I think
it was designed with the idea that I
might leave the phone around without
locking it but I think it's better to
just trust the user that the user will
know when he or she wants to lock the
phone itself and not and you know having
to enter the password every time you go
in to get at this different password is
a user annoyance so that would be my
comment yeah phones are much more
personal devices than computers so yeah
keep in mind again a lot of the security
considerations you've made you had to
make on a computer that makes sense in
the context or phone because it is
something a user typically carries in
their pocket but then you know if you
really really do want to put this
consider making it a time delay and not
just a non background delay
our next question from moderator is you
get tagged performance versus custom
holder class for cells in a listview I'm
storing view references using view dot
set tag fine view by IB and then
retrieving via you get tagged simpler
and less static I'm not really sure what
that means alright well i mean i'll add
you haven't you haven't used you know
this for a grid view which behaves
pretty much similar to list view you
know there's really no harm in using set
tag and get tagged I mean it's there for
you to go and store your custom data
whatever that might be so if you find
this an appropriate place to put you
know metadata references to objects
using etc that's perfectly fine you know
just keep in mind though that you know
your list few cells do get reused um but
as long as here you keep that in mind
you know where you decide to put your
data doesn't really make a difference um
I trying to figure out what he means by
versus custom holder I like assuming
that that means something like a
external hash table heat off of the the
row ID or something like that one thing
that you would run into in which where
view dot said tag would be much better
option is that as Trevor was saying the
views get get recycled so if you were
using like an external hash table or
something like that you could have a
hundred entries in there with just with
with the with a view stored in there one
you only really need like seven and that
situation would sort of take care of
itself if you just use the view dot set
tag alright cool next question then
thank you very much Alex the next
question is from moderator again with
GCM will there be any third-party social
servers available for us to use as
otherwise stuff like Twitter pushes
difficult and pricey to implement I'm
not really sure what's meant by
third-party social service observers all
that Francesco the answer it's no Google
Cloud messaging is a messaging service
which means that your server can send
messages to the cloud so we deliver it
to the device but we don't provide any
kind of extra feature like bringing down
social messages or whatever if some
developers could create a third-party
service that other users could use but
it's not google so the one thing that we
that might be worth mentioning they're
one of the new features we did a dingy
cm is you can actually have multiple API
keys associated with a single
application so you know as a completely
hypothetical example you know if so if
Twitter wanted to go and push messages
directly to your app they could go and
give you their own API key you could add
that as an authorized keep your app and
then Twitter would be authorized to send
directly into your app right now I'm not
aware of any social services that do
that but the functionality is there so
if anybody does want to go and build
that out the backends already in place
for that I got that right right cool
great thank you very much grubber okay
go ahead Matthew
though
hello this is a mad I had a question on
basically a DB tool when installing
devices on to an emulator we're using
code that's either generated by ASM not
necessarily just compiled in Java and
the get air is like Dex opt failed or
failed uid changed and trying to find it
if there's a way to find a general area
that just lists kind of where to go if
you when you encounter those types of
errors I know what they mean but we're
like I see index op is kind of like a
Java lying verify error but with much
less details yeah I'd say I mean our
documentation there is somewhat sparse
partly because you know most of the time
people don't interact with those tools
directly is you know anything that what
causes errors is normally caught it an
early level by the compiler and such if
you are going and trying to do your own
custom build you know the chances of
running into those are a bit greater so
unfortunately you know like I said not
much documentation there on at least on
the Android developer site probably a
good resource would be the Android
developers mailing list a lot of us in
Google on the the Android team within
Google do keep an eye on that so you
know there's members of the framework
team members of the the build tools team
you know we all stop in there every now
and then and so if you do run into
anything more complicated areas like
that you can just go ahead and ask us
directly certainly not not not as good
as having documentation but it's
probably the next best thing okay thank
you yep thank you ok let's do we have
anything else on ok my producer says no
so let's move to moderator I implemented
a simple after push notifications to my
phone but I ran into a problem billion
entries in the JSON sent to the GCM
server were converted into strings in
the intent extras is that a bug or a
technical limitation um it's more like a
technical limitation so GCM we open the
JSON protocol in GCM only but we want to
be able for you guys to use GCM on the
very first release of push messaging
which happened in Froyo devices now Froy
devices when we used see to the M for
the
they accepted only plain text in which
every parameter was a string so we sent
down to the device only only string
parameters like it's a is a key value
pair of in which every single value is
represented as a string so when we open
the JSON interface we had to convert
into strings what we are thinking about
is maybe force the JSON to have only
parameters with things okay thank you
very much Francesco next question from
moderator is it possible that daily
device installs also counts existing
devices that got a software update to a
new android version on a certain day I
had AV user installs and 450 device
installs there was a spike on for dot 03
dashboard on 04 device installs that
thing okay uh so Google Play does make a
distinction between a radio join us
which cameras yeah Google Play does make
a distinction between install new
installs versus upgrades so as far as
the data we're logging we definitely do
know the difference we need the two of
them I'm certainly not going to you rule
off the possibility that there's a bug
in our logging pipeline but to my
knowledge assuming everything is is
working the way it was designed those
installs should be different you know
it's entirely you know it's possible to
that maybe just got a bunch of traffic
from some other source and your update
you know made sony notice your app you
know if you may be installing like
google analytics which will get you a
little bit more visibility into you know
where your users are coming from how
many unique users you have that might
help distinguish between the two of
those I've certainly never heard of
updates being counted as new installs so
I'm really inclined to think that
actually those are new installs for some
reason with your app so like I said give
people Google Analytics try see if that
helps at least do you distinguish where
those users are coming from it'll tell
you things like refers lots of lots of
really juicy stats they're all right
Thank You Trevor yeah I just was I stole
Alex's thunder he's the he's the
analytics guy great regarding GCM what
ports need to be opened on our server
behind a firewall only HTTPS which is
443 or five two two eight five two to
nine and five to thirty or all of them
okay so if you're a server is the one
that sends a message is and is the only
piece that you want to use for GCM in
this case and then the port 443 is the
only one you need but if you have
devices that needs to receive messages
then the poor you want to open your
firewall is 5228 and which is enough for
now but you might want to open as well
5229 5230 because we might use those in
the future okay great thank you very
much next question of a moderator are
their docs coming up for using create
App Engine backends option in GPE there
was a great talk in google i/o about the
same thing but until now no docs have
been released when i click google create
App Engine back-end it exits with an
error I'm assuming that you're referring
to the crate App Engine back-end for for
an Android application and you haven't
just randomly put an app engine question
in an unrelated Android talk the that
plug in that particular function uses
c2dm to communicate back down to the
Android device and given that c2dm is
now deprecated I'm not actually sure
what the future of that plug-in is off
the top of my head I can look into it
but for the for the time being I know
that there are documents if you already
have a c2dm account there there is
documentation up there is the gb plugin
has its own page so that you can look at
there's also a page up on Android
training
and the I can't really say anything
about the error saying without knowing
what the actual yeah it's general guide
when you guys do see an error and you
want to ask us it helps if you actually
tell us what the error is but yeah I
mean more generally just talking about
the plug-in I'm not aware of any plans
to deprecate it I think if something
isn't working I think that's just a a
legitimate bug please file a bug report
and we'll look into it you know in
general android com is the Android bug
tracker now or you of course leave a
comment here with additional information
but again we do need to know the actual
error alright Joe thank you very much
gentlemen next question is are you
planning on selling the adk 2012 at some
point in time for those who couldn't
make yo if not what would you say is the
next best alternative go ahead Trevor
alright so right now I'm not aware of
any plans to have google selling the
educate the adk version to directly that
being said we have published all of the
schematics and no in various board
layout files online so anybody who does
want to go and make one everything is
open source I want to say it's creative
commons don't quote me on that check the
license associated with it but it is
released under permissive license so
anybody who does want to actually go in
manufacture more of these boards just go
ahead download them from our website and
you know at some point in the future I
suspect you'll actually see some on the
market from somebody's not Google who's
actually gone and reproduced them they
do take if for those of you who haven't
seen it it's actually a really cool
design they took the ADK and built this
really neat touch-sensitive alarm clock
around it and then we actually want to
go and build a joshy pop it open it at
some magnets and rip the adk out of it
it's really cool but it's also a lot of
work to build so I think it'll probably
take a little bit before people actually
release the exact same ATK that being
said i'm sure you'll also see some non
alarm clock ATK's for sale as well too
for somebody who just wants a simpler
hardware platform to go and build on top
of i just want to add the
the ATK that we gave away last year was
it was followed up within a couple
months by by several third parties
writing their own ATK's and selling
their own a TKS and many of them were
more impressive than the one that we
gave away so I wouldn't I wouldn't worry
too much about getting your hands on one
of the ones that we gave away at i/o
just go to the website and sort of keep
your ears open like check out like a
maker faire type communities and more
awesome stuff that's better than what we
gave away will be will probably be
coming down the pipe good answers thank
you very much so let's go down here to
the next moderator question on and this
is going to be one that Francesco can
answer why are GCM multicast message is
restricted to 100 to 1000 registration
IDs um as opposed to a dozen one now
it's actually a good question well the
API is a multicast messaging which means
is not broadcast which means you don't
want to send the message to everybody so
we had to come up with a with a number
now the number it's 1,000 is a kind of
the maximum we wanted to go at the
beginning because it we see spikes so
every time we receive messages we can
have like a sort of a eq PS right c2dm
we have like a very nice curve of GPS
but now we can have spikes of people
sending like it has a message in one
request which is very difficult to
allocate for our resources we wanted to
give this kind of API because it's good
for our developers to be able to in one
request address multiple devices but we
had to come up in a number and this
number was a thousand okay that's good
enough answer I think I hope yeah I hope
that answers your question on if not I
if you've got any other information that
that causes you to ask this I'd be we'd
be interested in hearing it meanwhile
we'll move on to the next question I
have knowledge of Android SDK Android
tools Jenkins
um aunt mia van XML and JSON maven okay
yeah that's probably true didn't think
about that what else does an Android
developer need to know to enhance his or
her technical skills everything yeah
that's why that's quite the question
there yeah I would say one thing I do
notice missing from the list is a sequel
and for persistent storage we use a
sequel light database so i would throw
that on the list of things to cover yeah
other than that that that is quite a
broad question yeah opengl would be a
very good topic to learn just because at
some point you'll probably want to do
something 3d if not you know a full
fight 3 game you maybe you just want to
go and build some effects into your
application opengl tends to be very good
tool for that in addition you know just
general computer graphics right you know
if opengl doesn't do what you need to do
you're going to be stuck with something
like a canvas and you know knowing how
to actually go and do things efficiently
in that context is a good skill more
broadly speaking you're going to want to
know how to do things with web services
so understanding concepts like rest o
auth things like that very useful to
know really this is it's a very broad
question here i could just go down the
list all day but yeah I'd say you've
already got a pretty strong foundation
there it really depends on what it is
you want to build right you know you
meet you i mentioned open jail maybe
that me has no bearing on your app i
don't know i don't know if you want to
do but i'd say you already have a pretty
strong technical foundation with what
you've listed i would certainly agree
with that i would also say that there's
really no end to the answer because you
can't ever tell what you're going to
need to know a lot of it to my mind
depends on what you're trying to
accomplish if you are trying to get a
position someplace with a company that's
doing something in particular than i
would look at what that company is doing
what type of application space it's in
if it's very data-oriented you probably
want to look at something like SQL or on
you may want to look
statistics and learn something about how
statistics and analytics are done in
this space on the other hand if you want
to be a contractor and independent
developer one of the things you're
probably going to have to do is decide
on what's most in demand and then focus
on those areas and you may have to sort
of pick up technical skills along the
way as you're doing a contract um
there's you know it's there's no way to
say that you're ever finished with
learning stuff that's certainly true I
think that's a pretty good answer yeah I
mean Trevor covered a lot of the things
that I would have covered especially
OpenGL I think that's a really good
answer so let's move on is there a rough
estimate for when c2dm will be turned
off and I think we've got the expert
here that may be able give us an answer
so c2dm is a deprecated which means we
don't accept any more signups nor record
a request we do not want to break your
application so we will give if we will
ever turn them the service is down we
will give heads up way ahead of time
like at least a year before we decide to
do so they said I would urge you to
migrate to the new system before you run
into quality issues or if you need to
use in your api's or the client login
which is being deprecated you will
actually be deprecated yeah I mean just
to follow up on that you know whenever
we deprecate an API it is a good idea to
go and take a look for alternatives in
the alternative in this case would be
GCM and to move there as quickly as you
can again we don't break your app it's
not going to disappear anytime in the
near future you do have time to do a
nice orderly migration but please don't
wait to migrate until we actually say
that the servers are going away because
by then you'll be in a rush start your
migration to GCM now and then you'll be
in good shape for when they do
eventually get turned off in the future
great thank you
next question okay if we thought the one
before was open-ended I'm trying to
learn java can you rent them in some
books or videos etc I'm sure we're all
going to have opinions on this one but
all I'm going to take a start the the
part that you didn't give us that's
really important is are you
inexperienced or intermediate programmer
who just has been exploded exposed to
Java yet or are you not used to
programming if you're already familiar
with programming I got a lot of value
out of a book called core java and also
1 i'm like you on the name maybe you
guys can help by a josh block it had a
lot of really had a lot of really good
design patterns effective java thank you
generals really good book but difficult
to digest if you are not already
familiar with programming if you're a
new programmer it's been pretty good I'm
pretty sure pretty close to a decade
since any of us have been new to
programming so if we knew good resources
a decade ago they're out of date by now
anyone else won't take it back of this
yeah I'm actually to take a opposing
stance here and say that I have hated
every java book I've everywhere that
being said there are some amazing
tutorials online so you know what used
to be the Sun website is now the Oracle
website they have a lot of job at
orioles they're all of them were
actually really well written I can't
recommend them highly enough so you go
take a look at those perhaps of you know
they have the you know the most of them
are in tutorial format they're written
by the guys who did a lot of the initial
work on the Java language so yeah that's
what I'd be my recommendation also if
you are going to branch out into Android
I can recommend a very good android book
which would be the one written by the
guy sitting on the other under the
camera right now ray Domeier its Android
for application development and you know
he's not on camera so he can't really
speak to it but i'll give him i'll give
him my recommendation from the side of
the camera and i would agree with
Trevor's recommendation I would also say
that the
books and videos and everything is going
to depend a lot on where you're coming
from if you've done programming and
you're coming from another language you
may want to take a look at books out
there that i'm sure there is some book
that is like java programming for C
programmers or something like that and
if you just google that you may find
something that will help you if you are
not familiar with object-oriented
programming then you may want to look at
something that's a little bit more
elementary that covers that as well as
Java from the point of view of somebody
just starting out I happen to have a
book called Java in a nutshell which is
an o'reilly book and the reason i have
it is that it does cover it is a good
introduction in the sense that it takes
you from very simple to very complex but
it's also a really great reference so
since i can't claim to be a java expert
i always have it sitting around in case
i need to look up something which I find
very easy to do in that particular book
the only other thing I can think of is
that a lot of things these days are
discussed in terms of general
terminology for computer science related
to programming languages so you may want
to look at books that are just in
general about object-oriented
programming and design patterns I
sometimes read a book called design
patterns which is at least a decade old
if not 20 years old at this point but
it's a good summary unfortunately in C++
rather than Java of the standard
algorithms and design patterns for
creating things in any programming
language and that's worth having on your
bookshelf but actually Francisco since
you're our guest today right uh you know
what's your opinion what would it was
there any books or anything you find
particularly good when you were starting
at learning java for the first time you
know a learning java when I was in Italy
in the book's title a lot of different
than surface my opinion is if you are
new to
I'm to program programming language I
would not start with the language itself
I will start learning algorithm lace
suggested because um you can build up
the foundation of programming skills
which will help you then pick up a
language which is java sea or Python
whatever much quicker and faster and you
know I've ever bit deeper understanding
of the code rather than have an approach
of I know this java library so I'm going
to use that without really understanding
what's happening thank you very much um
since we're on this topic that it's dear
to my heart I'll say one more thing
about this which is sorry which is that
the fastest way to learn any programming
language is to set yourself a project in
it I thought I knew Java really well in
target until I started working on
Android and then I really learn java
because you will learn something very
fast if you have to work in it every day
and if you've got a target at least
that's my way of learning so you know
look at the ways that you've learned
other things and follow that if you
learn out of a book then get a book if
you learn by doing then I would say go
do something all right okay um let's
move on next question is is semantic
zoom as implemented an ICS calendar a
recommended pattern to use in our own
apps I actually don't know what two
mantic zoom is yeah I don't either sorry
ah ok I think what the question means is
is expanding and expanding with the two
finger gesture a recommended pattern to
use in your own apps and unfortunately
don't have our capture device hooked up
I'll always be to actually show you what
Alex just showed us but he took two
fingers and just was able to drag up and
down and the the calendar view expanded
and detractors he did that
element of review expanded and
everything else sort of stayed the same
which i've seen is what they mean by
semantic zoom a recommended pattern it's
I don't think it's an official
recommendation at this point I would
check the Android design guide for that
but it it looks neat and if they're yeah
and if you no it didn't I think it
improves usability at least for the
calendar app so it's it's definitely not
a discouraged pattern i but i don't
think it's an official pattern yet
either it's just it's a neat thing
that's out there I have I can answer
specifically for something i dunno about
notifications in jellybean notifications
implement that feature as part of the
API now notifications at least used to
be what we call one you which is a
height of about I think it's 64 DP and
now we feature an expanded notification
if you do adjust your light I'm
stretching the boundaries of the
notification apart or some other
gestures you'll expand it to what's
called a for you notification with a lot
more space it's 256 DP and that's sort
of a zoom multi when I would call it a
multi-touch zoom and that's an official
part of notification you I at this point
so it's worth looking into on the
broader topic of UI design patterns I
mean there's certainly a lot of stuff
that we try that you're we think looks
really cool or you greatly improves the
usability of the system hopefully the
two at the same time you know and we
give those a try in our own apps we're a
bit more conservative with the official
design guidelines because once we write
something down there it's more or less
set in stone right I mean developers go
and they build up their apps using those
patterns so you want to make sure that
anything we actually go and write down
is something that we're really happy
with I think that this particular
pattern that was mentioned in the
question is not actually been added to
our standard or UI guidelines as Alex
mentioned if you want to go and be on
the bleeding edge you know by all means
try and make your upload let the system
I think it's a very good
all I think you can't go wrong that
being said you don't be surprised if in
the next release some of these things
change out from underneath you is just
like using undocumented API is write
these things are still in flux but you
know actually I think that back it's not
as bad API that's a thing don't ever do
it um but now I am if you I don't think
you can go wrong in this case if you
just want to make something that looks
like the system yeah just keep an eye
out and when what comes after when the K
release comes out whatever that happens
we called you know make sure that that
behavior hasn't changed I would also add
that this is a shiny visually appealing
feature that doesn't necessarily mean
it's appropriate all the time in general
I agree with Trevor that if you want to
look like system you can really go wrong
but we also put a lot of effort into
making you know visually appealing a
little a little effects like that where
appropriate that's true yeah there is a
guideline that any day you want to have
lots of you know a playful visual
flourishes it make sure I feel more
alive it makes your users happy so even
if things aren't necessarily documented
as official patterns if it makes sense
in the context of your app and follows
the spirit of the system it's you know
that that that the higher the
overarching goal there is something we
have written down I was a I was actually
more referring to in general i agree i
was more referring to like being
cautious when using a feature like that
like you know don't set up a text view
where you or use that feature and expand
like one word so it and you know so it
overlaps all the other words because
that would be oh yeah you have to make
sure you have to make sure it's usable
you have to make sure it actually makes
sense exactly but at the same time
having something that is usable and make
sense by this fun is a good thing you
know Kate case in point let you know
Google+ right when i get a vent
invitation it's like an actual event
card you like a little piece of paper
unraveling and I you know it's it has no
practical use but it it looks cool and
it makes people happy and it doesn't
hurt usability at the very least it
actually might even help
help explain what's going on right I
would add that some of these things are
sort of settled but there are force
multipliers that means that you have
immediate ability to look at information
in depth and take action without having
to go to another activity or application
so for instance in notifications you can
click buttons and look at more than one
email message that's a force multiplier
because what it means is you're not
forcing the user to go into email to
look at what's going on or go into a
music player or a chat system they can
look at it right from the notifications
they can look at a calendar event in
detail without having to switch to a
separate activity to look at it and
that's very powerful it makes things
look it's easy to use but it means that
there's less work for the user um I have
to give credit to Daniel Sandler for
that yes go ahead
no this right right so um the question
was can you use a Content observer
instead of content provider to monitor a
database and if not can you suggest
another way of monitoring the database
and this sounds like a familiar question
I think we've discussed this before um
if not officially in developer office
hours amongst ourselves um I'm not sure
what the answer is anybody got an idea I
am as far as the sort of content
observer versus content provider 140 I
don't know the answer off the top of my
head either it's I'm drawing a blank but
yeah I mean there's certainly more than
one way to go and read data out of a
database know at the end it's all going
to boil down to a SQL statement
somewhere it's just what design pattern
do you use to go and retrieve that data
and make it accessible to everything
else rado you you are you literally
wrote the book on this so what's your
thoughts if you want to content observer
it monitors of cursor right as far as I
know you should be able to it yeah I
think a cursor is a cursor yeah cursor
is a cursor and content observer there's
an observer on cursors that I think is
independent of content providers right
on the easy answer is look in cursor and
if cursor has a a a set content observer
method on it then you can do it because
that's how you would do it is set a
Content observer for a cursor that comes
from a database I mean a content
provider all that it really does for SQL
databases is encapsulate an SQL
database and the SQLite database returns
a cursor and the content provider
returns that cursor to the calling
component so really that's all the
difference that there is there's nothing
magic about a content provider that
automatically does an observation
anybody else okay yep so yeah this is
actually probably good tend to mention
that we have about 15 minutes left so if
anybody does want to go and ask us any
live questions please jump into our
hangout we have you happy to have you on
the air even if you're Mike doesn't work
feel free to hop on any way you can go
ahead and type your question out to us
and we can go ahead and ask our our
panel of experts here in the room GCM
questions or just Android questions in
general we're happy to take any of them
good point great
two separate bills EG ESPN trunk could
be running on a variety
okay so the question is is it a good
idea to run separate versions of ADT on
separate builds and the answer is uh my
answer would be on you certainly can't
do it in the same version of the clips
because those are plugins nique I don't
think you can have more than one ATP
plug-in in the same version of the clips
you certainly would run into problems
but if you want to have more than one
instance of eclipse on your system then
you should be able to do it yeah well
there is one problem I can see with all
this and I mean so the goal here is not
only have different versions of ATT but
also different versions of the android
framework running to correct um so in
that case uh you know there are
different versions of a DB server and
the different versions of the framework
are going to try and launch different
versions of a DB server and that's going
to cause conflicts so I think even if
you're running your different versions
of the SDKs have different versions of
ADT inside of different versions of
eclipse at the end of the day you can
only have one version of a DB server
running and that's where you're going to
run into problems yeah that is a good
point um you'd probably have to do a lot
of fiddling around with path variables
and environment variables in order to
get it to work correctly it's probably
not worth doing I would think that
probably what you want to do if you're
just trying to aim at different
platforms is set up for the highest
level platform and then you can always
aim to a lower API if you want to check
for API compatibility yeah I me now all
at one additional data point here you
know here in the Android team we work
with a lot of different versions of the
android framework and I have never
installed more than one copy of ADT so I
think that's not the right approach here
I think the right of approach have one
version SDK tools one version of ADT and
you know like Joe said just go ahead and
you switch what your build targets are
and that's something that's a perfectly
supported workflow great thank you um
next question from moderator Google Maps
home the work features are an API
available
for developers to access this data
intense or a provider or something i'm
researching location tracking for my app
I don't know exactly what the question
means but I assume that uh that the
respondent means the thing that tells
you how long it's going to take you to
get from your home to work and vice
versa right I think so too which I
believe actually was something I think
that's part of the whole your latitude
umbrella right where it's actually going
keeping track of where you are and
reporting it to your friends than
building a location service on top of
that the answer to my knowledge is no we
don't have an API for that we do have
location manager you can get you know
both your fine grained GPS location data
as well as the coarser grained you know
Wi-Fi base data as well but we don't
actually have the APS say you know where
is my detected home whereas my detected
work etc I would say actually if there
is an API for that we're the wrong ones
ask because we don't we don't run or we
we don't write a latitude or google maps
I believe Maps API has their own office
hours I that would be the right place to
ask yeah I'm familiar with the current
v1 version of on the Maps API for
Android and I don't think that it has
anything like this in it now it doesn't
arm but there's there's also i think
this is not a feature of that component
i think this is more a feature of the
maps app and the latitude API that the
latitude app and i don't think that they
have api is available so go ahead is
there there is a latitude API but I
think it's more for just reporting what
your location is I don't think at least
last time I looked at it which
admittedly was quite a while ago they
didn't have anything to go and get your
auto detected home and work locations
okay well I stand corrected which is
pretty much par for the course today um
well no no the answer is there's no api
for this right the answer for this
particular question is there is no api
sorry um if you've got any more
particular questions you can send them
in to us or call get online and talk to
us about it there may be something that
we're missing I feel like there's more
to this question that we haven't
answered so I just want to leave that
open um next question from moderator is
I'm using the following function to get
all view IDs versus calling fine view
I'd view by ID multiple times which does
a very similar traversal um any has it
in a link I'm guessing this is faster if
you have a high ID versus non-id view
group unfortunately we don't i don't
have off hand the link available let me
go look in the link and see if it's um
getting a redirect so he has a a
something called a we create resource
map okay he's literally just iterating
through all the the children inside of a
view group and then yet creates this
resource map which is I'm not sure what
data structure that is there um I can't
tell off hand but um I I think what he's
just oh here here go he's like he's
actually area if resource ID is not
equal to vo no ID and then he said all
right oh I see ya mm-hmm I mean honestly
I think you're overthinking things a bit
fine view I by ID is normally the right
way to do this and unless you're seeing
no actual concrete performance problems
which you can use by you know you can
find that out by using a profiling tools
you know things like traceview you know
unless you're actually seeing a negative
performance it there i'd say this is
probably a case of premature
optimization the seems like going a bit
overboard to me I've never seen anyone
go out of their way to go in and scan
through every yeah I mean skin through
all your your child feels like that
seemed a little off but that's being
said you know I'm not going to discount
the possibility that it might be more
you might be faster in certain
situations but really just depend on how
you're using it but again unless you're
seeing a performance impact it seems
like code you might not even need to
worry about I would say if you are
seeing a performance impact and that's
actually making it faster the only way I
could see that being true is if your
view hierarchy is so complicated and
nested that you have much bigger fish to
fry yeah if you if you have hundreds and
hundreds and hundreds of of your views
that you're trying to call fine view by
ID on I'm really terrified to think what
your view hierarchy actually looks like
that's if it's you're going to be your
to spend more time rendering then you're
going to find spent searching right okay
um let's move on here how does the
tablet layout of Google Play manage to
display two pages at once when you
scroll over to the categories section of
the viewpager hmm yeah I'm not sure what
you mean by display two pages at once I
suspect they've just gone and created a
view that displays both sets of
information at once you know could be
done using fragments that's you know the
sort of thing that they're designed to
be very good at and you can certainly
stick fragments inside of a view pager
so I think that's the answer the magic
of fragments okay thank you next
question from moderator do you have any
plans on integrating Facebook or Twitter
and Android as ample did with Twitter
hmm no comment yeah
yeah is our hardest fixed by any chance
know all right yeah we do see a time
machine is not working we can't tell you
about things that we may or may not do
in the future yeah it's stuck on the
shelf not moving anywhere right
sometimes it has cookies inside but okay
next question does the remote control
client API only support the flag
comedian next flag media pause and flag
key media previous controls other flags
do not seem to show up without looking
at that API on the top of my head I'm
not sure any of us know the answer I'm
not sure what you mean by don't show up
either do you mean it doesn't work or
it's not in the documents better than on
the documentation ah well if they don't
show up that's probably a good
indication they don't work yeah okay um
since we're getting low on time we'll
move on I'm looking for a way to overlay
a drop shadow on a scrollview was
described here with a link how can i
overlay a drop shadow onto a scrollview
is this possible it looks as if the
whole o dot light action bar does the
same any answers um are you waiting
every for the link but I'm not sure I
actually know the answer having never
tried to overlay shadow on top of a
scrollview um so I think that what he's
trying to ditch hose sort of a layout
and he's trying to put a drop shadow on
top of something that's in the details
my intention that has another layout
above and outside the scroll view that
stays at the top all scrolling the
content of the scroll view the skull of
you should have a drop shadow overlay at
the top which appears to be from the
layout above but you certainly can place
views on top of other views there is an
implied z-order and I think depending on
which type of
which type of let major Ying sometimes
you can even specify the order of ember
Hartley but um yes if that's the case
then just create a yo a a shadow as a
drawable with a with an alpha layer and
problem solved short of that I'm there
are other things you can do to try and
fake that but I not think of anything
that will work really well in the case
of a scrollview well that she know there
is there is a a I was throwing for like
a heading section on scroll views where
you can actually go and you normally
it's designed to go and have a title for
your scroll view but you could put a
drawable in there to put your shadow as
well that's a hack but it'll work well
yeah it's not I mean from what I'm
looking at here it's not really clear to
me whether he's trying to put the drop
shadow on the scroll view or on the
title above the scrollview so arm I
can't really tell if you're putting on
the title above the scroll view that's
even easier then you just place a
drawable at the bottom the only thing
that makes the scrollview difficulties
is going to move from but you know I
think you know assuming you're putting
your whatever your green box here is on
top of your scroll view just take
advantage of the order is probably the
easiest option I think that's a good
answer okay let's see if we can move on
ah next question it sorry yeah okay
we're going to have to make this the
last question my producer tells me so
how can I notify each fragment in a view
pager which is linked to a tab post to
refresh its view data following a loader
finishing in the main activity yeah how
can I notify each fragment in a view
pager linked to a head tab host to
refresh its view data following a loader
finishing in the main activity I mean
generally speaking the way you want to
go and communicate with fragments is
using you know define it in our face and
just make a a call to all of your
fragments then have your five months ago
and update what's inside of them I
usually recommend against reaching
inside of fragments to go and try and
manipulate whatever whatever view
components are inside of it because then
you're you're breaking capsulation the
ideal with a fragment
is you can go and swap it out with other
you know fragments as needed and it is
portable once you go and start modifying
the contents of fragments you've broken
that portability so short answer send a
message to your fragment and have the
fragment update itself anybody else have
any insight on that no he has posted a
large set of code on Stack Overflow that
we could to go take a look at him in
more detail but but probably not in the
30 seconds that we have left yeah
unfortunately sorry um sorry we're out
of time um but we are out of time and
and we'll have to take a look at it in
Stack Overflow and hopefully somebody
else can step in and take a look at it
as well I encourage everybody else in
the Android developer world to go to
stack overflow take a look at this
questions if you've got any ideas about
what's going on that's a lot of people
yes crowd sourcing the answer and on
that note I think we're done for today I
want to thank Francesco for showing up
in answering GCM questions and Trevor
and Alex for supporting me and raid 0
for running all the equipment to bring
this to you and on that note goodbye
everyone